[Music]
Kylie Jenner pulled out all the stops
for her 21st birthday and et is taking
you inside the reality stars all peak
hardness ice like it's the whole gang
the whole family's here look an
eyewitness
exclusively tells et the
kardashian-jenner crew came together to
celebrate Kylie's bday @h would groups
Delilah in West Hollywood Thursday night
the venue was transformed into Kylie's
pink paradise filled with pink furniture
party favors jello shots and eight ball
pit our insider adds the staff working
the event wore Kylie's Forbes cover on
their shirts and the Kardashian ladies
also stepped out in their very best I
want to wear things that make me feel
good about myself and still feel sexy
Kim keeping up with Kylie in a satin
pink cutout dress torrid sizzling in a
cleavage baring purple mini and Chloe
flaunting her incredible post baby
figure in a sparkly two-piece
but nothing tops Kylie's head-to-toe
pink outfits she slipped into a sexy
dundas dress for dinner then made a
quick change into her party look a
diamond-encrusted wrapper featuring
70,000 crystals with a matching chain
purse momager Kris Jenner shared a toast
to her youngest daughter and Stormies
parents couldn't keep their hands off
each other
Kylie's sisters also seem to be living
it up at the bash snapping sister pigs
captioned we're all turning 21 and the
now legal live kick creator taking shots
with big sis Kim and I witness tells et
Rob Kardashian and Khloe's man Tristan
Thompson were missing at the bash Dave
Chappelle was one of many stars on
Kylie's VIP guest list which included
the weekend Cara Delevingne Ashley
Benson Draya Michele and friendly
co-parents Kourtney and Scott
[Music]